you know it's very easy for the the
Socialists of the day the Bernie Sanders
crew to say that we should be more like
Sweden and Sweden of course is a very
very tiny country that was homogenous
for many many years
ethnically homogenous that now has
having all sorts of immigration problems
so Sweden was great until the non-whites
came in that's interesting people can
rewind that and re-watch that hopefully
you know nobody over there Media Matters
pulls that clip alright welcome to this
installment of Devil's Advocate I'm your
host Skylar turn today we do have a
guest on here who's been here by request
so we do try and honor the audience
requests here he has a show now used to
be I want to make sure I'm clear here it
used to be with the Young Turks and is
now available at works with blaze so
kind of a change there you can go the
SUBSCRIBE sign up support them I guess
at blaze tv.com slash Dave mr. Dave
Rubin thanks for taking the time to be
here Skylar it's a pleasure to be with
you people say that I don't talk to
people on left enough and I thought
today we could just have a healthy
exchange of ideas and see what common
ground we can find so do you have that
like a patented or trademarked exchange
of ideas you said that a lot we're
working on putting it on on a sweatshirt
right now I just trying to find the
right distributor all right well I
distribute I guess before we get it was
Glenn Beck so you work with him now so I
want to make sure I understand before we
get into canceled culture that
transition what are you doing there the
blaze now with everyone else there who
likely only a few years ago were
victimizing your marginalized class but
tell me what it is that you're doing
with him now well I've decided to join
the the far-right potentially suspected
assumed all right blaze which of course
was founded by Glenn Beck and has people
like this steven crowder guy who's a
real radical and Mark Levin and Allie
Stuckey and a couple other people I mean
it's a pretty it's a pretty out-there
far-right group of people but I thought
I would join them to moderate them a
little bit you know what I mean cuz I'm
a little more centrist maybe I could
moderate them and then of course you
know people I think maybe from your
community would say that I'm doing this
for the money because it's a big grift
and I hey I do have to tell you that if
you're if you were going for the grift
the grift would not be going to the side
that gets called racist and homophobic
and bigoted and all that you would you
would go to the woke side so I just want
to be on the record about that yeah yeah
well I appreciate your trying to throw
me off the scent was this idea of big
woke money but I'm not gonna bite so
before we can cancel that that that
beanie looks pretty pricey if you're
asking me oh well I don't know what that
is I'm from Toronto we call it a toque
oh but no listen I appreciate you can
use the wrong term I but you also use
the word here regardless let me ask you
this um Kancil culture i don't want to
misrepresent you were going to talk
about this and as it relates to de
platform a lot of people have been
complaining about it however how would
you define or characterize sort of
canceled culture because I know you
fancy yourself an advocate for free
speech at the forefront yeah well I do
believe in free speech I believe that
the First Amendment in the United States
the idea that is enshrined into law that
you can say anything you want and the
government can't stop you from saying it
with with some seriously strict lines on
what you can't say meaning that you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater and
that sort of thing and we have very very
specific libel laws but outside of that
we have free speech you are allowed to
offend people you're allowed to say what
you think it doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be consequences for it
people might not want to associate with
you or something like that but what's
happening now is that if you take any
position outside of what the
progressives on any given day deem good
and it changes every day is that a vape
you've got there
it's CBD nice nice
yeah it helps with the concentration I
know well I it also points to military
overlooked
you know I know you guys don't think
that's a real thing but you know I don't
want to interrupt you I don't want to do
it you know I don't want to do you guys
do over there at the place I want to
give you as much of the floor as
possible so it'll make it that much
sweeter when I um break down this house
of cards just make sure you make sure
you put on your rainbow flag mouth guard
so this Tim can I kick doesn't hit you
in the teeth well for the record I do
believe in stimulatory overload because
I'm on Twitter so I understand all about
that but the point here being that on
any given day what the progressive woke
religion decides is good or okay or
acceptable on any given day if you take
any position counter to that they will
often go after your job they will go
after your family they will Docs you
they will try to deep platform you and
this doesn't mean that everyone on the
right is perfect and the right has done
some strange things over the years but
you know we've got a little bit of a yin
and yang here and right now by and large
the the scary conservatives and
libertarians are far more open-minded
and decent and want to live in a society
that that actually lodz having people
with different opinions and and and you
know I hate to say it but you guys the
the progresses you've you've become a
secular religion and if anyone doesn't
agree with you all the time they must be
destroyed I don't I don't consider
myself a secularist or a member of any
religion at all you're not a secularist
or a member of a religion no I I do I
want to make sure that so you believe
that conservatives are more decent
because they want to live in a world
where they can yell the n-word or yell
the f-word but I wanted could not that
you want to yell like cf you know like a
pejorative toward people from your
marginalized group you believe they're
more decent because they believe in
defending that right I want to make sure
I'm just not misrepresenting you here
yeah well first I should be clear I am
in no way marginalized I am a human
being with equal rights equal rights
that that you have and that I would
imagine
virtually everyone you know has but I
yes I do want to live in a society where
you're allowed to say whatever you want
you no offense it is on the side of the
people who take it so if you were
getting down the street let's say and
someone said Oh God look at that guy
with his what what do you call a beanie
again took a toque and that ridiculous
mustache
it's and his you know your leis on
shooting to you you know and his lesbian
like shirt and all that and someone said
some mean things to you well it's on you
to decide whether you're gonna take
offense to that but but the option let's
say you said okay I'm not okay with
someone being alright saying whatever
they want to say the option is we're
gonna start jailing people for speech
now of course this is actually bizarrely
where the the left wants to go at this
which is why they label everyone Nazis
because why would you let a Nazi speak
so we're in a we're in a slippery slope
here and you know well I appreciate that
mr. exchange of ideas went straight to
ad hominem this is not a lesbian shirt I
purchased did it Orvis there happen to
be lesbians who shopped there but I
consider myself an ally and it's a
beautiful experience and sometimes we
shop together so I don't necessarily
know how that's relevant to my ideas but
let's talk about sort of cancel culture
because you said you want an exchange of
ideas but you also seem to have a
problem and I see this with a lot of
people on the right they get upset
one the free market wins out when
there's a boycott for example and people
get removed or S&L as a recent example
where this man hurled a bunch of
anti-asian racial epithets I can't
believe a comedian said something mildly
offensive I you know it's I'm trying to
you think that's acceptable well he what
he said I want to understand like gee do
you don't believe that NBC should have
the right to monitor and control what
goes out over their airwaves because
that's the free market right they
decided they didn't want this deplorable
rhetoric well yeah yeah well and NBC is
welcome to do it they want their a
private company right and if they don't
want to work with this guy because of
something he said in the past then then
so be it I certainly wouldn't want the
government forcing NBC to keep this guy
you know if they didn't want to as a
business decision but that being said
you know comedians like I think you
might occasionally work with this steven
crowder guy you know do you know him
no I cut him a wide swath know I've
heard about
yeah so he or other comedians say Jerry
Seinfeld or Dave Chappelle or some of
these guys what a comedian has to do
George Carlin would be a good example
Bill Hicks what a comedian has to do is
get as close to the line of what's
acceptable as possible to push the
limits of the way we think about things
and occasionally when you do that you're
gonna cross the line so whether the guy
intentionally said something racist or
not or whether Michael Richards from
Seinfeld years ago with whether he was
trying to be funny when he said the
n-word repeatedly or whether he was
being inherently racist I mean the point
is these people need to exist in an in a
in a free society that's gonna be a
little bit a little messy but I'll give
you a good word for it
the Gestalt of all of that is what makes
ideas flourish and that's the society I
want to live in so the companies can
decide who they want to work with and
the people can decide you know what
content they want to consume well you
say that but you've also been along with
many other members of the alt-right on
this crusade against big tech and social
media where you don't believe that they
should have the right to control the
speech in their platform which
effectively is like forcing them or
having the government forced them to
amplify speech that they find hateful or
disagree with why would you want to do
that for example with a YouTube or a
Twitter why don't they have the right
the same First Amendment rights right
corporations are people to hear the
knock Glenn bet the other Mormon MIT
Romney say it why is why is that that
okay well how is that consistent with
your worldview
well first off Skyler I do have to
correct your premise here because I've
actually never called for any
intervention I've had discussions with
this with people like Tucker Carlson who
does want some intervention now and I've
had people on the Left a guy like Eric
Weinstein who also wants some sort of
intervention my preference would be that
the market can solve these things and
that's why I started my own tech company
and we're building out some technology
to free creators but the real issue here
is what are these companies are they
platforms where everyone can be on there
and then as long as you're abiding by
the terms of service you can be on there
and do whatever you want
the publishers like you know CNN is a
publisher of their content or the blaze
is a publisher of some of this radical
right-wing stuff that you've mentioned
here right and and then they have
different responsibilities so if every
time Twitter or Facebook or YouTube if
every time they censor someone it
happens to be someone on the right then
they've moved from being sort of an open
platform to an actually a publisher of
content and then there's different legal
responsibilities my preference would be
to just keep putting stuff out there in
a way that they would treat us all
fairly but if they're not gonna do it
then I'll make some solutions for myself
so I think that's pretty consistent with
the worldview that I've been espousing
but have they ever argued that they're a
platform because it seems to me the idea
of fairness would be predicated on the
idea that they are a public platform
have they ever made that claimers that
you copy-pasting something there so that
you have no I'm fairly certain that at
even at congressional hearing some of
the the bigwigs there have basically
gone on the idea that they are platforms
although then when they talk it out a
little bit more they start sounding like
publishers but that's you know that's
sort of in the weeds kind of legal
mumbo-jumbo what I would say more
broadly is that if you are someone who
creates content whether it's political
stuff or video game stuff or you're a
knitter or a nun boxer or a vaping
expert you should be I don't claim to be
an expert I didn't claim anything and I
also don't do political content I
consider myself a citizen of the world
of humanity and we all have aligned
interests if we're believing that we are
all moving toward the same path to
enlightenment I think some of us are
further along the path but one could say
that politics let's say you were you
were into the knitting lesbian shirts
whatever it might be I would say that as
long it's it's a very lesbian shirt oh
no I'm sorry this is Eddie Bauer and I
did go with my lesbian friend but she
doesn't shop at any bar she went to
Orbis afterward that's why I got
confused because this is what happens
with radicalization you know you threw
that out like lesbian shirt and
Dave Rubin with by the way LGBT are your
the are you GRU be I'm gee I you know I
don't want any special credit for that
you can speak to me at normal speed and
you know you can use whatever pronouns
you want I'll be okay that's fine but
you threw out lesbian shirt you me not
as a joke but then someone else you know
next thing you know no no I mean that
very seriously it's a it's a very
lesbian shirt alright and we all think
this is super fun this is what we can
expect from the alt-right which is why
they don't have any late-night programs
on main networks right now but you know
my girl Lily saying now is out there at
NBC so good for her but here's the thing
someone else takes that they expand upon
that they take that as license to
mistreat people who wear quote-unquote
you know the lesbian uniform and then
the next thing you know I'm going to
Eddie Bauer with my friend and she's
getting abused a hate crime is committed
right she just wants to go to orbit and
but but because Dave Rubin wanted to
make a joke and thinks that that needs
to be protected
all of a sudden marginalized classes
have to live in fear and so this idea of
free speech at you're defending I don't
know if you've ever heard this it
actually is anti free speech because it
intimidates the oppressed into silence
most of the lesbians I know are doing
quite well I don't know any oppressed
lesbians I know some pretty power I'm in
LA here I know some pretty power
lipstick lesbians who are certainly not
oppressed but you know it's it's a fair
point and I should I really should think
about that I don't want to just look at
someone in a flannel shirt and assume
that they're a lesbian
you're right I should work that through
I'm gonna think about it it's also not
thank you it's also not flannel it's a
peak cotton but let me ask you where's
the line then I guess that you think is
acceptable you said there are very clear
parameters as to what's allowed I'm sort
of social media what you can say as far
as free speech is the line at calling a
black person the n-word you like I said
the f-word earlier or using other like
lispy queer something like that which
we've heard before or you know racial
pejoratives referring to someone it's
Mexican what
everyone has a line where is yours where
does it cross into the realm of being
unacceptable right so first off I would
say that each of the platforms have
their own Terms of Service and they can
decide wherever that line is my personal
line would be that if you are on one of
these platforms because they've become
our new ways of communication like you
know 40 years ago you had the telephone
and everyone had access to the telephone
regardless of what you were saying on
the telephone as long as you are a free
citizen in the United States right so I
would prefer that as long as you're not
breaking any of the laws of the United
States that you could be on these
platforms and be treated fairly now the
problem with that inherently is that
you're gonna get a lot of people that
are gonna say mean things they are gonna
say the N word or the F word or the C
word are there any other words that I
have to say a letter for I prefer yeah I
prefer to not use any of the pejorative
so yeah I use descriptors and I try to
use them in a way that is not as
stimulatory overloading as possible yeah
so that would be you you'd really have
the whole letter to a were at the B word
the C word the whole thing but in any
event I would prefer that all of these
platforms because they are the they are
the way we communicate in a moderate
world that they let anyone on as long as
they're not breaking the laws of the
United States now ironically sometimes
people in America or in Western
countries get kicked off these platforms
for not obeying the laws of Pakistan so
that's another problem but I using an
extreme example to make a point David
this is what you do you act as though
there's the United States and the
founding father who had no idea that we
could be phony fathers we had no idea
that there would be I phones and social
media you say so we either have this
Wild West as completely sort of
libertarian utopia in the United States
or Pakistan right and what about all of
the European countries or or places like
Canada that do have hate speech laws in
place yeah that's those are those are
have you been to any of those places
I've just been I was on tour and I
performed in in Sweden and in Norway and
in Ireland and the UK and a bunch of
other countries and you know they're
very jealous actually of our First
Amendment
you know if you listen to the the
lefties on Twitter especially the blue
check celebrities they'll say oh I just
got back from Europe and in Europe
people were saying to me what happened
to the United States and it's just
simply not true I mean I was there and
people are absolutely jealous they still
look at the US as a beacon of freedom
they look at our protections around
speech and and even around firearms and
some other things as ways that the
people can fight tyranny so I'm four you
know it's very easy for the the
Socialists of the day the Bernie Sanders
crew to say that we should be more like
Sweden and Sweden of course is a very
very tiny country that was homogeneous
for many many years
ethnically homogeneous that now has
having all sorts of immigration problems
where were a country that has brought in
more people from more countries in the
world then anywhere in the history of
the world and we've done it better than
anybody so I don't think there's a
better place than this good ol US of A I
want to make sure they understand so
Sweden was great until the non-whites
came in that's interesting people can
rewind that and re-watch that hopefully
you know nobody over there Media Matters
pulls that clip and look forward to the
Media Matters people pulling man what
about you like just ask you something
about Media Matters every time Media
Matters gets retweeted into my timeline
because I don't I don't follow any of
these fools these media matters is a
nonprofit organization and they spend
all all day they spend watching what's
scary people like this Ben Shapiro you
have you heard of this guy this this you
know four foot eight fast-talking Jew oh
yeah I'm on the program and I mean it
was you know and I want you to hold that
thought but yes I did have him on the
prod you want to answer your question
I've heard of him I had him on the show
and I've talked about this before as
someone who I'm not a member of a
religion but I'm a very spiritual person
yeah and when Ben Shapiro was in the
show he was like looking into the
lifeless eyes of a doll I truly felt
spiritually disturbed like I was in a
struggle against evil
I know been fairly well I I had coffee
with him last week I've never had that
feeling about him but that may have been
you were doing it via Skype and
sometimes staring into that camera
can be very soul sucking you know
there's certain there's certain tribes
out there that don't like having their
picture taken because they feel it
steals the soul you may you may have a
distant relative in a community like
that mom well it only took us 19 minutes
to get to you bad-mouthing tribes which
we hear that I hear the sound of a dog
whistle you mentioned you were Sweden
Ireland UK where else did you perform
Sweden art well we went to Canada which
is up north here in the United States we
went to about a hundred stops here in
America definitely went to a couple
other countries you know we went sit we
went to Denmark that's another socialist
utopia that's what you know that's what
the lefties will tell you but I noticed
no like South Africa for like a week
Cleveland we did go to Cleveland
actually we didn't get to we didn't get
to South Africa we did go to Australia
no and did you know this about Australia
they've got kangaroos just running in
public so you're just driving your car
in a kangaroo just like that was that
like another racial pejorative no no a
literal kangaroo really I all need to
make sure our banned dictionary literal
kangaroo because I'm just not I'm not
always up I don't like you said you
don't follow Media Matters I don't
follow the neo-nazis in the alt-right
like I don't have David Duke of my
timeline so I don't know what literal
kangaroo means but I mean I can guess
based on well yeah go on urban
dictionary I'm sure it's on there um so
let me ask you don't think that there
would be any benefit in the United
States to having european-style hate
speech laws I'm not talked about
censoring speech we're talking about
speech that is hateful not being a lot
in public discourse you don't think
that's not something you would be on
board with Skylar you're you're a
well-intentioned guy and I hear you but
you know the problem with that is who
gets to decide what hate is right so
your definition of hate might be a
little more narrow than my definition of
hate and once we've given that power
away to the government the the expansion
of what hate is will basically keep
growing until anything that is counter
to whatever the the current orthodoxy is
which in this case is usually some sort
of postmodern leftist
conflated lunacy everyone will be afraid
to say anything so I would rather live
in a society where somebody might say
something you don't like
they might and and you got a [ __ ] and
keep trucking right bad I would I would
rather live in a society where we listen
to the victims of perpetrated hate it
seems to me it's pretty easy to
determine listen to the people who are
victims of hate speech not the ones
perpetrating the hate speech right so if
somebody said that you sexually
assaulted them but could provide no
evidence but said that they were a
victim hmm would you be would you defend
them for that
well I'll discuss that issue because um
that was put to rest from my sophomore
year and we don't need to talk about any
more but I do think that we should
believe all women and investigate it and
unlike what's you know that for example
right now new allegations about Kavanagh
no no there needs to be impeachment so
there's an investigation because no one
believes any of these victims which i
think is horrendous um and it sounds to
me like you're doing the same thing as
victim blaming as it relates to victims
of hate speech be it racial be it sexual
orientation gender you know I'm kind of
old school here and I would say that you
need evidence to actually prove
something and if you can provide
evidence then we can have a chat but
just saying something happened in and of
itself is not enough because they'll
come for you my friend
even you Skyler who's obviously a very
upstanding you know very productive
member of society and and on the right
side of all the issues who care about
other people and minorities but even you
they might come after you I don't
consider myself a productive member of
society but that's because I don't
consider myself as far as Society has
not been inclusionary with people like
myself I don't consider myself the
benefactor of current societal norms
that's why I'm a citizen of the world
and humanity and my life is not
determined by the parameters of the
legal structures that be or oppressive
structures that be is determined by my
path to enlightenment so I understand
what you're saying but not on consider
myself a productive member of society in
a
I'm actually rather proud of that fact
yeah I wish I had my vape some of that
would have made more sense to me I'm
well I don't think the faith is gonna
help you if you don't understand what I
said it was pretty pretty simple and
plain speak I mean I didn't quite go on
some kind of a soliloquy like you're
your friend there um you're alright
friend mr. Jordan Peterson but um I
thought it was straight to the point
I'll let the audience make up their own
mind let me ask you this though the
market will not solve the problem of
radicalization on YouTube right this is
something that's a real problem
different studies that have come out
that have shown you all right and the
alt light even though you sometimes say
you're not all trite but you entertain a
lot of these people from that community
people migrate from your community into
those viewpoints do you not see that as
a problem that as members of the human
race we should work toward fixing as
opposed to relying on corporations well
this is where I'd say it's it's so great
that we have a wonderful press free
press here in the United States because
wonderful newspapers like the New York
Times they cover stories like this and
you may have seen this about two months
ago in the New York Times they ran a
story about radicalization right on the
cover of the sunday New York Times
radicalization you know to the all right
by youtubers and they included I was an
unnamed or so people like my included
people like myself they included people
I believe like steven crowder who i've
mentioned a couple times again shady
character they included people like
Jordan Peterson invention Pierrot Atta
and then and some real radicals like
Milton Friedman and Phil DeFranco I mean
it was a real list and then at the end
of the article they tell you this story
of a good liberal who sort of became all
right but then guess what it's so great
he was saved by lefty you tubers and
then ended up as a progressive so the
important thing is that we have a good
media that's gonna watch and safeguard
our freedoms and not throw people under
the bus and try to destroy people and
smear people and even with Cavanaugh
right now the New York Times is doing
such wonderful work and it's so great
that that they're still out there doing
it what do you mean by that I assume
you're being
but seems to me like if Cavanaugh forced
his uh his his twigs and berries in
ladies hands that that should not be a
person sitting on her Supreme Court well
you know again they're gonna have to
provide some sort of evidence but that's
not really what they're interested in
doing you might have picked up I was
being a little sarcastic there you know
you did you did get me well I wasn't
entirely sure because I thought maybe
you weren't familiar with the facts of
the case interesting talking about
radicalization I see you mister Dave
Rubin as a byproduct of that I mean you
used to be with the Young Turk for a
while Andrew who said that that you
didn't leave the left the left left you
which I believe you cut right into a
bumper sticker and now you're all the
way way over at the blaze I don't even
know how you could define yourself as a
centrist anymore but you certainly
veered more and more far right do you
not see yourself as the byproduct of
radicalization these people you've
mentioned to been Shapiro's of the world
the intellectual dark web like you have
changed as a person and that's alarming
well Schuyler I have I would say I have
a radical belief in human freedom I
believe that you Schuyler know what to
do with your life better than anyone
else I believe that if the government
gets out of the way that you can figure
out what is best for you and your your
girlfriend or boyfriend or lesbian
friend I believe that you within the
community that you live if you're given
the opportunity to be free and the
government doesn't take a lot from you
and just makes sure that we aren't
killing each other and stealing from
each other that that is the best way for
human flourishing and the same would go
for me or anyone else even that radical
guy steven crowder what I keep
mentioning you know who's got pretty
out-there political beliefs I want even
someone as radical as him to live freely
so what I would say is if if being for
freedom is far right then yes I would
say I'm a far-right radical there you go
far-right radical I appreciate it we'll
take that clip um yeah I think that's
important to know
though that people are free like use it
to talk about whatever does it want to
talk about but then we have these
ramifications and it seems me that
people on the right don't like the
ramifications whether it's Dave
Chappelle or Bill burr or our most
recent SNL example that they want there
to be a balance on these these networks
or even social media which just doesn't
seem tenable with the position of
believing in freedom that's what I have
a hard time understanding well we do
have a certain imbalance of who can say
what and when they can say it so the SNL
issue right now with the comedian what's
his name by the way I don't even know
his name do you know his name off the
top of your head Higgins something
Higgins so you know he he said he said
something offensive to the Asian
community and SNL decided to fire him
but the idea that Saturday Night Live
was which once by the way was an edgy
comedy institution and I didn't even
realize it was on so and I anymore I
thought you know I started seeing all
these tweets about SNL I thought my god
they're back after 20 years you know
it's sort of like that SNL is sort of
like the new york times of comedy shows
it's it's done but you know the name SNL
the name New York Times they still
remain but the the essence of what they
once were are gone but you know it's
like are you gonna go through what every
one of those edgy comics like Eddie
Murphy said over the years the brilliant
comics Chris Rock's right are you gonna
go through what they said and find out
well any of them said the N word or said
this or said that or said something
offensive and now we got to fire them so
again NBC can do what they want but once
you start taking out the comics it is a
it is a seriously dangerous situation so
that's why even a comedian like steven
crowder again who I've mentioned here
who's it who's a hate speech monger and
tried to destroy the career of a
wonderful young journalist from a
fantastic lefty publication called Vox
which is just a bastion of truth and
fighting the power it is even yeah even
steven crowder I would be for him being
able to say what he says and and I you
know he's he's as bad as it gets but
I'll defend him I will um well after
this interview
maybe someone might be knocking him off
to ledger you know you did say you do
believe it's the government's job to
prevent people from killing each other
you know he said make sure that people
aren't committing violence but it seems
to me if I've come through your your
talks quite effectively that you do
acknowledge I think you try to do so
with an islamaphobe o grant that the
Quran some people use it to inspire
violence words can cause violence right
so you acknowledge that so isn't that
within the purview of government
regulation because words can lead to
violence and that's really where the
conversation is taking place well it is
true that words can lead to violence in
that anyone could hear anyone speak and
construe any thought in some way that
perhaps it was intended or perhaps not
but we do have laws against a direct
call to violence but I would say that
any religious texts whether it's the Old
Testament or the New Testament or the
Quran or anything else is worthy of
criticism is worthy of of looking at
with a skeptical eye and it's not and
criticizing a set of ideas because of
religion as I'm sure you're well aware
is a pagan a religion is just the set of
ideas that are worthy of criticism and
and if you want to follow the words in
that text that's fine too but a set of
ideas is also a political platform or or
anything else a set of ideas is what
governs our ability to play sports there
are certain certain rules and you should
be able to be critical of any of those
things what you don't want to be is
bigoted towards people so I would never
say oh there's 10 Muslim people over
there they all must think the same thing
what I would want to do is talk to them
like I would talk to any other person
and say oh you have one set of ideas you
have another set some people do is my
point some people would make that
generalization and you are defending
their right to make that generalization
on what you referred to am Not sure that
facebook or youtube is asked for the
self to fact-check it a public forum a
public platform you are defending their
right to say that which can lead to
violence and and that's why especially
as someone from a marginalized community
I mean you know we don't need to go back
that far to see what was happening to
the Gees in the LGBTQ yeah
when you say marginalize oh so you're
talking about gay
because I'm a lefty I write with my left
hand that's what I thought you were
talking about no no also you died we
died a couple years earlier than you
people which is why we've hurt you by
the way you people left-handed people
died earlier yeah we died a couple years
earlier because you know the whole world
is a righty world so we crash into walls
more often right the scissors it's a lot
yeah well I think you probably probably
even out because you're short so the
taller people die younger by five foot
eleven and a half and and if I'm on
vacation really rested I'm a good six
foot well you know what that's something
that everyone from five nine to six foot
like to claim to six foot margin but
again I you know what let's let's hand
that to I don't want to get off in the
weeds here I want to help unpack this as
you've talked about but um it did this
is important if you may not do that
some people will some people will attack
or use their words to encourage violence
against marginalized communities and I
do wonder if someone who benefited from
as it is a benefactor from progressive
ideas you know like gay marriage why it
is now that you want to close that door
behind you for other marginalized
classes well what I would say is that
when you're talking about progressive
ideas I think what you're really talking
about are equal rights and equal rights
is a core tenets of classical liberalism
and conservatism and that I want
everyone and this is a radical idea so
you're gonna have to kind of sit in this
one I want every member of society so
let's talk about this from an American
perspective to have the exact same laws
govern them I don't want any special
treatment for anyone based on your
gender or your sexuality or the color of
your skin or your religion I want us all
to be treated exactly the same now I
can't force private people to use the
pronouns you want I can't force a
private company to hire you or not hire
you I can't make sure that there's no
bigotry or racism because it's part of
the human condition but what I can do is
fight for true equality which which just
means that we're all treated equally
then it's gonna take hard work it's
gonna take a little luck it's gonna take
all it's gonna take your your family and
community connections but
that's the beauty of life in a free
Western society it's like it's not
exactly even all the time but at least
the rules are even so I will always
fight for equal rules for everything I
don't agree with what you just you said
it's part of the human condition
I disagree vehemently I think it's part
of societal conditioning which is also I
don't agree with the precepts of gender
and the gender binary and that's why I
don't consider myself a member of
society I consider myself a member of
the human race right a global citizen
because I don't believe that humans are
bigoted I don't believe it's a part of
the human condition I believe
particularly it's a part of the
conditioning in Western society and I
should clarify I say pagan pagan for the
layman to understand I'm actually I'm a
vain Satanist really it's a lapse
laveyan satanism oneis a term which is
effectively an absence of beliefs but a
rejection of the classical Christian
power structures at peace so we're not
sitting there with you know an altar at
Bohemian Grove we actually simply don't
believe in the archetype of God as it's
been sort of preached that's that's well
yeah the beauty of what you're saying
there of course Schuyler is that I
believe that you you strike me as a very
moral decent person and at a macro sorry
at a micro level of course one can have
no particular set of beliefs and still
live a moral life but the question is
well not even a moral life just a decent
human life that's set up for other
people to flourish as well the question
is at a macro level at a societal level
can the set of ideas that you just laid
out maximize human flourishing and would
we ever be able to believe in the same
things so that we could build a society
that could withstand the forces of
barbarism and totalitarianism and
authoritarianism that's the question my
friend I hope you'll ponder that one a
little bit well it sounds to me they're
like you're advocating collectivism when
you're talking it does take a village
and I would say this as far as it
relates to society and I understand what
your stuff let me ask you this in club
before we go to questions what is where
can what are you doing with the blaze
what's the programming there it's at
blaze tv.com slash Dave we do have to go
in
yeah well yeah it's blaze tv.com slash
Dave and you'll get a 48-hour window on
the new episodes of the Reuben report
and it was a way of me securing all my
digital properties because the radicals
are coming for all of us and I know we
may differ on where the radicals are but
yeah I've always found you to be
respectful and decent and hopefully you
can spread that among some of your
comrades
I will do my best and I would say the
same about you if you didn't go straight
to the lesbian shirt and trashing your
sponsors like with Orvis or any power
but i would like to ask you this as you
mentioned societies sort of collectively
if we can agree to the same values and
then I'll express my view but what this
is collectivism that you're advocating
what would you like to see how would you
like to see society go forward since I'm
Eve railed against the platform and
cancel culture how would you like to see
the current state of our discourse
improved what would you change about
quote unquote composure and how would
that look yeah well just to be clear
Schuyler I am not advocating for
collectivism I'm advocating for what the
founders wanted which is that we have
certain we have god-given rights that
the government is there to protect the
government doesn't give us rights it can
protect those god-given rights and then
those rights are laid out in the
Constitution and in the Bill of Rights
what I'd like to see going forward is
more people more good decent
progressives like yourself willing to
talk about these issues clearly the vape
is helping you sort of you know take a
more open approach to this and I think
what's happened unfortunately is that
most progressive these days they believe
that they in and of themselves that
their own mind is knows exactly what's
right and that everything that came
before them was bigoted and racist and
awful and they're gonna have to hate
their grandparents and they're gonna
have to hate Barack Obama one day
because he ran against gay marriage the
first time and a whole bunch of other
things so I hope that the progressives
will take a moment and pull us back from
the ledge because I believe that most
people that live here in these United
States of America are pretty decent and
by the way my dog Emma who's been here
this whole time she's been very
quiet she-she-she agrees with me too
it's not it's not such a terrible place
here good ol US of A well I appreciate
that I appreciate you bringing em into
the conversation I did realize after our
last couple of conversations here on
devil's advocate that we do need more
equal representation of our sisters of
course in the good fight right now I
would say this Emma identifies as a cat
by the way well I think that's very cute
and I appreciate you trying to make a
jokes here about a very serious
situation where we have transgenders
being afflicted in attempting suicide
and record numbers but I'm glad that
that's fodder for a joke maybe you can
audition for SNL so I will say this calm
down there I will say this I understand
your view and you don't think it's
collectivism I do believe that it is
collectivism as far as a fundamental
value of society you invoked Yahweh you
invoked God you invoked a bunch of white
racists slave owners and the founding
fathers I would say this I believe that
society and I believe that the human
race is fluid I believe that we can
change who we are I believe that
together in one love and the spirit of
one love we can change how we interact
with each other and so as it relates to
society and its fluidity I won't invoke
those people that I will invoke the the
wonderful master Bruce Lee be water my
friends so thank you very much to
everyone I appreciate you taking the
time and me now listen I'll send you a a
peak cotton shirt when we're done with
this and don't knock it till you can I
just since since you use the quote there
can I just throw in one quote that I
like that I think might help you a
little bit no this is I'm just gonna
throw it in here this is from an
incredible leader throughout time this
is from Optimus Prime who was the leader
of the Autobots who of course were
fighting Megatron Starscream Soundwave
the Decepticons Optimus Prime said
freedom is the right of all sentient
beings think about that my friend I
almost took was Bruce Lee because he was
a sentient being and not a giant robot
in a Michael Bay film enjoyed this
installment of devil's advocate please
click one of these boxes you can see the
other installments with Ben Shapiro with
Jordan Peterson and other
we've had on this program gonna use the
term folks very lightly and I want to
clarify that there's nothing um lesbian
about this shirt and we value and
respect the wonderful and elegant
same-sex attracted wonderful women and
zeez of our community and this as much
as its marked I do advocate for CVD for
people out there who do have conditions
like lime or self-diagnosed ulcerative
colitis which is not an affliction to to
make light of